this semester i'm peter bartlett the
associate director of the simons
institute for the theory of computing
we established the rm carp series to
celebrate the pioneering role of simon's
institute founding director
dick carp in theoretical computer
science and we're grateful to the many
contributors to the richard m carp fund
who made this series possible
the series features visionary leaders in
the field of theoretical computer
science
on topics associated with current
programs running at the simons institute
and it's geared towards a broad
scientific audience this semester the
simon's institute's hosting two
online programs one on probability
geometry and computation in high
dimensions
and one on the theory of reinforcement
learning and i'm delighted to welcome
our speaker today
professor ronnie rubenfeld who's
participating in the program on
probability geometry and computation in
high dimensions
renee is the edwin sibley webster chair
of eecs
and a member of csail at mit she's
famous for her work on property testing
and sublinear time algorithms
algorithms that can give an accurate
output after seeing
a vanishing fraction of their input and
she's
won an array of awards for her research
and
actually for absolutely everything she
does awards for teaching for mentoring
and advising for inclusion and diversity
she's a fellow of the acm she's been a
speaker at the international congress of
mathematicians and this year she was
elected to the american academy of arts
and sciences
and ronnie has a strong berkeley
connection she's got a phd in cs from
berkeley
she's also a member of the scientific
advisory board of the simons institute
and we're very grateful for her
contributions there of course
so today we're delighted to have her
presenting a talk entitled is your
distribution in shape
welcome ronnie thank you so much for
that
really um generous introduction uh
and so i want to talk about
distributions today and in particular i
want to talk about
what you do when you get samples from
a distribution over a very large
discrete domain okay so here's the model
you get samples from some distribution
let's call it p
um you can press a button you get
another sample and we're going to charge
you per sample
we're assuming that this these samples
come over some discrete domain
maybe the numbers 1 through n or maybe
some other domains that we'll talk about
later okay but the main thing is this
domain is big
okay so there's some probability
distribution underlying these samples
but we don't know it so we're going to
use p sub i to donate denote the
probability that p
outputs i but this is the part that we
don't know all we can get
are samples and furthermore we have no
assumptions on our probability
distribution so
you know you may say i'm assuming my
distribution is gaussian lipschitz
maybe it is but we're not going to be
able to assume that in this talk
okay it's the kind of thing we want to
actually test so given
samples of a distribution what you need
to know
lots of things people want to know
what's the entropy what's the support
size
how close is the distribution to uniform
is it gaussian
is it zipfian what's the number of
relevant variables lots and lots of
questions and these questions come up
all over in statistics information
theory machine learning
databases algorithms physics biology all
over the place because they're
fundamental questions okay so
this is a talk about this shape
distributions
and shape um so what do i mean i don't
mean a
are you did your distributions do the
coronavirus workouts every day
i'm asking more about distributions that
are in some sense defined by their shape
and this is not a sense that is um i
don't have a formal definition for what
it means to be
a distribution defined by shape but
here's some examples
so you could talk about monotone
decreasing distributions where
the probability of element i
compared to the probability of element j
depends on the relation of i and j
so the distribution is getting smaller
you could talk about t modal
distributions where the distribution
goes up and down to most t
times or you could have distributions
that are well approximated as
k histogram distributions this is
sometimes called k
flat or k piecewise constant
distributions where you can represent
them in a very compressed manner
or poisson binomial distributions which
are really
just a distributions that are sums of
independent random variables but
they may not be identically distributed
log concave distribution
so there's lots of families and you
might ask you know why
why are these shape distributions i hope
to convince you that uh
we can actually look at them all in the
same class soon
okay and the key question for this talk
is how many samples do you need
in terms of the domain size which we're
going to use n
to denote okay and in particular do you
need to estimate the probability of each
domain item
in order to figure out if your
distribution has these properties
or because the problem there would be
learning an arbitrary distribution in l1
distance is known to require
theta of n over epsilon squared samples
or is there some way the sample
complexity can be
sublinear in the size of the domain so
that's the hope and in fact
um we're going to see that for these
problems this
the samples complexity can be something
sublinear in all of the cases that i
talked about
okay so let me just start with um
i need to give you the example of the
uniform distribution
it's the most basic shape property uh
and we're going to use it later in
the um in the talk so just pay a little
bit of attention now but a
suppose you want to play the lottery um
your
most basic question is is the lottery
actually uniform so how would you test
you're getting
these samples of some distribution it's
discrete how would you
test if it's uniform okay so a true
story
there was a polish lottery which
involved a machine that had
80 like it was a big machine it had 80
little balls in it
every day they picked out 20 balls um
and it turned out that the initial
machine was actually biased
so um here's the example so they did
in the first 300 drawings every day they
out of the 80 balls they took out 20
samples
okay so it's not id because when you um
exactly but you can see here that some
of the balls had were less likely to
come out the balls
numbered 50 to 60 had lower probability
and if you know this then you can make a
lot of money
on this particular in fact people did
make a lot of money
on this lottery so this is the case
where the domain size is 80
and it's discrete so it's a very small
domain and you could figure out pretty
quickly that there was a problem with
this lottery
okay but what about the new jersey pick
3 or pick 4 lottery i say this because
when we started working on this 20 years
ago i was
in new jersey and um we looked at the
pick 3 pick 4 lottery
the pick 3 lottery you pick three digits
in order pick four you pick four digits
in order the domain size is respectively
a thousand and ten thousand
um let's assume each day was independent
um and when we did this
twenty years ago in two thousand the the
peak three we had eight thousand five
hundred and twenty two past results and
if you ran it
in the chi-square test on windows 2000
it gave you 42
confidence of uniform pick 4 was worse
because
i had fewer results only 6 500 results
and note that the domain size here is 10
000.
so chi squared test on windows 2000 gave
no confidence
all right so we'll see in a few minutes
if maybe windows 2000 was being ultra
conservative but
it wasn't clear there because the number
of results
that we had to look in past history was
a lot less than the domain size
okay so here's the problem that we want
to look at right now
is the sample complexity of
distinguishing the case
where your distribution p is actually
the uniform distribution
from the case where p is epsilon far in
l1 distance
from the uniform distribution so well
one distance is just
the sum of the distances of each
element okay and it turns out that this
is
actually square root n over epsilon
squared
okay so this is something much smaller
than n
uh and
why do you need square root epsilon
what's a lower bound
um well think about the uniform
distribution
on n and then think about the case where
you pick a random subset of half the
elements
and put the uniform distribution on
those half of the elements
now any algorithm that distinguishes
samples
from either the total uniform
distribution or uniform on half the
elements
how is it going to tell the difference
like if it looks at the names of the
elements it sees
the names don't mean anything because
these guys in this side
on the the uniform on half the elements
they were picked randomly
so the names of the elements mean
nothing the only thing an algorithm can
do
is actually look at the collision
statistics okay
but there are no co okay where do we go
here
okay there are no collisions until you
get around root and say root n over two
row run over four
samples you won't see any collisions in
either case in both cases
it'll look to you like you're just
seeing completely random domain elements
coming at you okay so you can't
distinguish
these two cases in less than omega of
root n
samples so that's why ruden is required
the surprising thing is ruden is
actually enough okay
so there's a whole long history um let
me just say
people i don't want to get into too much
now but just let's say
people looked at counting the number of
collisions people looked at counting the
number of distinct elements in the
sample
there's even a version that's similar to
a chi-square test
that is actually optimal for all
settings so maybe those microsoft people
were being
the microsoft 2000 people were being
super conservative
didn't need to be uh and they're even
more surprising there's
something called a plug-in tester that
works and this is
actually the best so it actually
operates by trying to learn the
distribution
but how well can you learn a
distribution based on just root and
samples
terrible but still it's good for this
problem so the summary is
root n over epsilon squared samples is
what you need and it's good enough
all reasonable algorithms work well but
plug-in is the best
okay so i just want to say that's the
complexity here
uh there is some not so great news that
i need to mention
and because that was the problem of
distinguishing
a completely uniform distribution from
epsilon far from
uniform but what if i want to um
distinguish i what if i know that the
uniform
that it's not uniform distribution i
want to distinguish
epsilon close from much further okay so
i want to
distinguish the case i know that p is
not uniform
but i think it's epsilon close i want to
distinguish the k
p is very close to uniform from very far
okay and it turns out this is a much
harder problem because i have to
accept distributions that are only
epsilon close epsilon one close
all right so this problem becomes
something like theta n over log n
still sublinear it's still better than
learning
but it's a lot worse than in the other
case we call this the tolerant version
and it tends to be harder okay i also
want to mention
there's a related question we just
looked at the problem of testing whether
p is uniform
but what about another distribution q
okay let's say you write down q for me i
don't need samples of q
because i know q okay it's a specific
distribution
that we care about now what is the
complexity of testing where p equals q
or p is far from q
is it like uniform turns out yeah it's
exactly the same
okay so it's exactly it doesn't matter
um that q was the uniform distribution
it could have been any distribution
it's also root n over epsilon squared
for the non-tolerant version
and n over log n for the tolerant
version
we call this testing identity um for
some historical reasons that i can't
really
defend okay so there's a lot of history
here too
um and the summary of that
is a you can use chi-squared like
estimators you can use
collisions you can use reductions to
uniformity testing
so there's a lot of ways of doing these
things but everybody gets to root and
over epsilon squared okay so here's
well i mean so here's the point i want
to talk about monotone distributions
so what do i mean by monotone
distribution well
let's look first at totally ordered
domains
okay domains like 1 through n a
in here i'm going to talk about i'm
going to be a little confusing and i'm
going to talk about
monotone non-increasing distributions so
these are distributions
where um if i is less than j
then p sub i is at least p sub j
okay and this is a totally ordered
domain so
the domain element is the numbers one
through n
okay so these are monotone decreasing or
at least non-increasing
uh later i'm going to flip this on you
and things are going to become
increasing so um just to con just to
make sure you're awake
i guess okay so um
so we want to know what is the
complexity of distinguishing
a distribution p that's monotone from
the case where p is epsilon far from
monotone
okay so that is the question and
it turns out that testing monotonicity
requires at least root n over epsilon
squared samples
okay so it's kind of it requires at
least as much as uniformity
because a monotonicity tester would give
you
a uniformity tester with the same sample
complexity
and since we have a lower bound on
uniformity testing
we get a lower bound on monotonicity
testing
okay and to see this is pretty simple
here i have monotone p i can look at
p and p reverse okay so if i want to
test if p
is uniform all i need to do is check if
both
p and its reversal that is what i'm
going to do is relabel
all the input domain so that i reverse
i'm going to relabel
n to be element 1 and
n minus 2 to be element 2 and so on so i
have p
and now i've reversed the names of the
domain elements so this is p reverse
it's
the same thing but just backwards um if
p was close to uniform then both p and
its reversal should be close to monitor
so you see this p
is very far from uniform and in fact its
reversal is not
close to monotone decreasing decreasing
okay the only way they could both both p
and its reversal will be close to
monotone decreasing is if they were
actually uniform
and you can quantify this um the
you can quantify how close they are uh
and show that it's related to how close
p
is to uniform all right so we have a
lower bound
we know that testing monotonicity is at
least as much as uniformity testing
that's why i had to tell you about
uniformity testing first
but maybe it's much harder than
uniformity testing
and it turns out it's a little bit
harder than you i mean
we it turns out that we actually don't
know maybe it can be his hardest but
here's open question number one
can you do it in root n over epsilon
squared okay but what we do know is
root n is the right pretty much the
right
dependence on n up to poly logs um and
actually descalak is diagonalism
cervedio got it down to
a single log n that you have to get rid
of um and polynomial and one over
epsilon
many samples okay so i want to say a
little bit more about this
um one of the main ideas used
in this um algorithm is to look at
something called the berger buckets
a in it's a way of partitioning the
domain
into segments that are exponentially
increasing
okay so these are segments that increase
exponentially
they look like one plus epsilon over a
constant
raised to the i so the first few buckets
might have just one element in them
and then two and then they start to go
take off okay
sort of like coronavirus i guess but d
and in total we'd have
one over epsilon times log n mini
buckets so not that many buckets
just one over epsilon times log n and
the interesting thing
is if p is monotone
then when you construct something called
p-hat
okay so p-hat is going to be just like
p if you look at the bucket level
it's going to give exactly the same
distribution
weight to the distribution that p does
to each bucket
but what p hat will do is spread it
evenly along the bucket
okay so if this green line is p then
this pink line is p
hat it's just going to take everything p
gave to the bucket
and spread it uniformly
okay and what you can show
for this kind of p hat and this is true
only for monotone p
um then p minus p hat has to be close i
mean
it's not true only for monotone p but
for monotone p
then p hat has to be close to p
okay so basically we have this really
nice way of partitioning the domain
and it's super nice because it's
oblivious you don't have to take
any samples of the distribution to
figure out how to do this partition
it depends you see only on epsilon okay
so it's a super nice partition
completely oblivious and
we now have this p hat that we can
define it just
has to figure out what weight p gave to
each partition
and then it gives um it distributes that
weight uniformly
over the bucket okay but same
conditional probability per bucket
and if you do this then a mathematical
proof will show you
that p minus p hat is going to be at
most epsilon in l1 distance
all right this immediately gives you a
learning algorithm
for monotone distributions on one
through n
so this immediately gives you a way of
learning because all you have to do
is learn the weights of each bucket okay
so
you only have one over epsilon times log
n mini buckets
um you need something like one over
epsilon squared samples per bucket to
learn the weight
and that gives you a log in over epsilon
cube sample complexity
for learning monotone distributions over
one through n
okay but this is a talk about testing so
the hope is now maybe we can use a
learning algorithm to give us a testing
algorithm
okay so here is a plan for a testing
algorithm
we're going to learn this p hat just as
we said
based on the beer j approximation we're
going to estimate the weights
of the buckets but we're learning this p
hat
remember i just want to point out
something we have this theorem here
only for monotone p and we're trying to
test whether p is monotone
we actually don't know if p is monotone
okay so
we can learn as much as we want but if p
is
not monotone then all bets are off this
p hat
may not be close to p we have no idea
right so if p was monotone p
hat will be close to p and everything's
great if p is not monotone
p hat could be anything we have no idea
so let's learn p hat
estimate the weights of the bucket um
let's check that p hat
is close to monotone it might not be
exactly monotone
even for the uniform distribution um
because of sampling
errors you would expect that
these these average bucket weights might
go a little bit up or a little bit down
but you can just check that it doesn't
go too crazy
and you don't need any further samples
to do this
you basically have log n averages
um lp or brute force on a problem of
size log n
would give it to you um and this is just
a computational problem
okay and then we need to test that in
fact this p
hat that we've learned that's close to
monotone is
also close to p because it could be that
p
was totally far from monotone um
and the p hat we learned from p
is close to monotone but p was not close
to monotone
uh and so we need to test in fact that p
hat is close to p
okay and the issue here is we might need
some tolerance and if you remember i
told you before
that we can distinguish p hat and p
um if we can distinguish the case when p
hat and p are identical
which they won't be here in general um
from the case where p hat and p are
epsilon far
in root n or epsilon squared samples but
to distinguish
p hat and p epsilon closed from p hat
and p
to epsilon phi that already can take n
over log n samples
so there's a tolerance issue here but it
turns out that in this specific
case uh you can actually
test the p hat is close to p in root n
over epsilon squared
okay so there's a paradigm here where we
learn
the distribution under an assumption
check this this learned thing
is close to the property we want and
then we test that what we learned
is close to our original distribution
okay so that's that is the plan here
okay and now i want to talk about some
work with uh clement canon and elias
dick nicholas
and temesculiakis on testing via shape
which takes this paradigm
and extends it further okay so all these
distribution families defined by shape
such as the ones i showed you k flat
distributions log concave pbds
t-modal they are all
functions where we can describe them
as combinations of k-flat functions
okay so there's so i'm it's no so i
remember k-flat is the same as
k-histogram and it's the same as
k-piecewise constant
i'm going to use the name k-flat because
it's the fewest letters
and it's the easiest to say so we're
going to use k-flat functions to
approximate these classes
and we're just going to have a general
paradigm where we're going to show that
any one of these
distribution families that we want to
test can be approximated by
say an order log n flat distribution
okay so
any t modal distribution or any monotone
hazard rate distribution
can be approximated by some t log n flat
distribution
and so our generic algorithm strategy
will be
find a k flat partition of the domain
unfortunately we don't have a
non-adaptive way of doing that like we
did for monotonicity
but there are algorithms such as in batu
kumaran myself
um of finding a partition adaptively
uh and then we'll estimate the weights
of the k
flats as we did before and then we'll
test that our learned k-flat
distribution is close
to our original distribution okay so
this is sort of a general paradigm
um and then in the end we have to check
also that our concise approximation
is close to having the property and that
is usually something
that is a computational problem as
opposed to a sample complexity problem
so no new samples are needed here but
you need an algorithm usually some type
of linear program
okay so this type of paradigm
has been applied can be applied um in
the paper
with clemont alias and temes uh to
all of these uh function family
probability distribution families
monotone k-modal law concave monotone
hazard rate
binomial poisson binomial k histograms k
piecewise degree polynomials
k sums of independent integer random
variable values
um so it gives you one paradigm for all
these different
a classes and it either
these have all been studied before so it
either gives you
the same sample complexity or improves
on the previously known sample
complexities
and one thing i should say is acharya
descalakas and come up
have a completely different paradigm
which is not shape-based
and applies to exactly the same classes
so
um okay so that's what i want to say
about that
so now i want to talk about testing
monotonicity of distributions
over general postsets what we talked
about until now is
the total order posted okay so it's a
total order
now what if you just have partial orders
okay so
monotone distributions over let's talk
about some general postset domains and
what we mean by monotone over these
we're going to represent our domain as a
graph so each domain element will be a
node
we'll have n nodes and we'll have
directed edges
between node u and node v if u is less
than v in the partial order
and we'll say that given a distribution
p
over the nodes it's p is monotone if for
every edge uv
p u of u is at most p of v
okay so this is um
so i just just to point out that i
flipped the direction here
because before we had non-decreasing um
sorry
i think we had not things were
decreasing and now things are increasing
okay so that's a in case that's
confusing
all right so lots of works um i'm given
a bunch of examples down here
have considered specific posets um
and i'll say a bit more about them this
is the line posted that we just
considered
and we saw that that was theta tilde of
root
n um people have looked at grits and
noticed that the
the sample complexity gets exponential
with the dimension of the grid
um the matching poset is kind of a
strange poset and you might wonder why
anybody would look at that
i hope to convince you that it's a
little at least a little bit interesting
uh it just takes domain elements pairs
them off
and puts an arrow between them um
and then there's the hypercube posted
which is what i'm going to spend
most of the rest of this talk discussing
okay
so um the matching post up by the way
um is we know the complexity of testing
whether distributions on the matching
postset are monotone
it's theta of n over log n for the
hypercube we have a lower bound
of n to the one minus theta of square
root epsilon
and an upper bound of n over log n for
testing and
that's what i want to talk about is
these two i'm going to say a little bit
about
these two results okay
so let's just make sure we're in the
same page about the boolean hypercube
domain
um the hypercube domain uh it's boolean
so we're
viewing each node as a d
bit string okay and
so the size of our domain is two to the
d
okay and we're going to say that x is
less than y
if the i-bit of x is less than or equal
to the i-bit of y
for every i okay so um
in this this is typical to make a
picture
of these this is the um this is the
dimension 3 hypercube it's typical to
draw a picture with the all zero node on
the bottom and the all ones
nodes on the top and you put arrows
between nodes that differ
in exactly one bit every time a zero
goes to a 1
you put an arrow so here we had 0 1 1
the first 0 went to 1 so we put that
arrow okay and now
i'm less than or equal to anything where
i have a directed path
okay so that's the notion of partial
order on the boolean hypercube domain
um this more generally we could have d
levels
and we draw it kind of like this we
typically put all the
nodes at the same that have the same
number of ones
on the same level so level zero is the
all zero
level d is the all ones and level i
would be
it has i ones and d minus i zeros
okay so
what about testing distributions for
monotonicity
over the boolean hypercube and it was
known actually
a somewhat general bound for testing
monotonicity of
posted distributions is that if the
underlying posit can be decomposed
into a union of w disjoint chains of
length l
then you can get this weird bound of o
tilde of the width
times square root the length
as a testing bound and that you know
never mind how that works but that
yields for the hypercube
slightly subline your time testing
result
okay it's actually two to the d is the
number of nodes in the hypercube and
um it's divided by d to the one-fourth
okay so that's what we get we're going
to get a somewhat better bound
right now but i just want to mention
that because
there are somehow this actually this
lemma is not specific to the hypercube
uh it is it is good for any postset so
sometimes it could be useful um
but let's go back to our learning to
testing regime that we talked
about earlier again we wanted to
learn some sort of approximation to our
distribution assuming that p was
monotone
we want to check that this thing that we
learned is close to monotone
and then we want to check that this
thing we learned is actually close
to our original distribution so to do
this
we need to have a way of learning
monotone distributions
over the hypercube so the question is
can we learn monotone distributions
over the hypercube in sublinear samples
so we saw a way of learning
monotone distributions over the total
order with sublinear samples
but what about the hypercube because
that berger decomposition
doesn't hold okay um and in fact there's
a lower bound of
omega 2 to the 0.15 d
samples that's implied by something
called telegram-like distributions which
i might say more about later but it's
not that important
it's just a family of distributions uh
uh that we um know
we need some it's going to be
exponential
in the dimension okay so it does not
rule out
sub linear time lower bound i mean we
might have an upper bound that's slub
linear
but it does say that a the learning
problem
can't be made say polynomial in the
dimension
for for hypercubes okay so
um okay but
i'm going to show you a learning
algorithm for the hypercube
which is still exponential in the
dimension but
it is sublinear in the domain size
okay so it's um the domain size is n
and it's divided by 2 to the log
raised to the 0.2 and samples so it's
slightly sublinear
but it's better than what was known okay
and then given this we're going to learn
our p-hat
we're going to check we're going to
learn our p-hat
check that p-hat is close to monotone
again no further samples will be needed
um
our algorithm here is not going to be
sublinear time
this thing that i'm showing you today is
sub linear samples but not sub linear
time
subliner time for this problem is
actually open
um but so this step we can't do in some
linear time
but then we will test that p hat is
close to p and here we're going to need
tolerance
uh so we will need to be do this do this
with the n over log n samples method
of valiant and valiant so all in all
this is going to give us
this n over login dominates the time for
the
the learning complexity so overall this
will give us an n over log n
sample monotonicity testing algorithm
okay and if you can get a better way to
test that p hat is close to p
then maybe you could get a better
overall um because
this is more time than we need to learn
p hat so this is the dominant step
okay so that's um how we want to use it
so i want to say something about this
learning algorithm
for monotone distributions over the
boolean hypercube
and in order to do this i want to
define a notion of tight and slacky
elements
so if i have a monotone function even a
distribution
then monotone means that
the function value at x has to be
at least the maximum of
any anybody that precedes it any y that
precedes x
um f of y okay so this has to be true
for it to be monotone that's definition
of monotone
we're going to say x is tight if we have
equality here
so that means the value of f of x is
exactly what it needs to be to be as big
as its predecessors
but no more that's a tight
input x okay otherwise we're going to
say x is slacky
all right so let's do an example well
let's take
a distribution p that's uniform in the
upper half
so it's probability 2 over 2 to the n on
the upper half
and 0 on the lower half all right so
let's take somebody right in the middle
row
so it's one of the ones that's 2 over 2
to the n
but it's above all zeros
okay so we have an element of weight 2
over 2 to the n
everything beneath it is 0. so this is
slacky
okay um but if i picked
an element that was either well into the
red
area or well into the white area these
guys are tight
okay because they're exactly equal to
the maximum of their child
of their predecessors okay
another example so that's a tight
example another example
is um these are this is what we refer to
before
the telegram functions these correspond
to
a dnf min terms which is why it's
interesting in complexity
um so these points here um
once you set these to non-zero
everything above it
has to be at least their weight but
these guys being non-zero
are slacky because they're big all their
children are zero
and they're positive so they're slacky
everything above it is determined by its
value
okay so these are a what we call the
telegram functions
and that's another example but notice
here there's very few slacky elements
all right so why are we interested in
slacking versus tight
well as a motivation to this algorithm
there's a beautiful lemma by blais
hastad cervedio anton which i'm going to
restate
and this is actually for complex they
developed this dilemma for a complexity
theory reason
and it's in it was in ccc they
considered monotone boolean functions
and what they said is let's say i have
this function
f and it's got slacky places all over
the place
i can clean it up so that
it's slacky on only very few possible
levels
okay so i can write f as approximating
it's approximately some g function g
which is slacky on
only a constant number of special levels
and this constant
it's independent of the domain size it's
independent of the dimension d
it only depends on epsilon okay so
very few places where we have these
slacky points where
actually the distribution bump or the
function value bumps up more than it
needs to
to um be monotone
all right so we extend this to
distributions
um we have to get something a little bit
stronger
um in particular we have to bound the
total weight of these special levels
where the slacky stuff happens
but that's a a
but get with this strengthening and this
extension to distributions as opposed to
boolean functions um we get a very
similar
type of lemma in kind of
philosophically at least and let me show
you
how this lemma can lead to the algorithm
so
let's assume that we are in between
slacky levels
okay so basically between slacky levels
i want to clean nothing interesting can
happen
okay so i have this value x
and the largest predecessor y
is uh let's look at his largest
predecessor
well x is equal to the value of his
largest predecessor because
x is tight so p of x equals p of y
everything in the middle since p of x is
equal to p of y
has to have the same probability value
okay well what does that mean it means
that when we take samples of our
distribution
we're if we take enough samples so that
we hit this
then we're going to fall into this green
area and we can
estimate the total weight of this green
area and if we can
estimate the total weight of this green
area then
we because p is constant in this area
we actually know the problem a good
estimate of all the probabilities of
domain elements in this area okay so if
i know it's constant in this area
and it's big enough that i can sample it
then i can know what these probabilities
are or at least a good estimate
of all these probabilities okay this is
only true for the largest predecessor
of x so if i have another predecessor z
that doesn't have as much weight as as y
then the weight in the area between x
and z is not going to be bigger because
i picked y to be the biggest one
so this weight area is not going to be
bigger
but i i mean and there's some chance i
would confuse z
for y only if the probability of z is
very close to the probability of y
in which case everything's fine because
i will have still a good estimate
okay so that's the main idea we're going
to look for all x we're going to look at
all its predecessors on its um previous
slacky level
these are going to be big little um big
little areas
big areas here um we're going to
estimate every single one of these the
area between x and y
the area between x and z and the area
between x and
any other predecessor on this line and
pick the biggest one
and use that as my estimate of the
weight of
p of x okay that's the whole idea
and the reason we can do this is because
we have very few slacky levels
so i have a lot of room here i have a
lot of weight here
i don't need that many samples to fall
into this area
whoops i didn't want to do that okay
sorry
okay so i don't need that many samples
to fall into this area hopefully
okay so that was the important thing is
i need a lot of space between
these points i need space between
x and the next slacky level whenever x
is far away enough from the slacky level
the green area is big enough that i have
samples that fall there and therefore
i can estimate these probabilities
that's all we need
okay and that is the basis of the
algorithm
so that's the algorithm it's just what i
described we're going to compute p hat
of x we're going to look at all y
such that y is a predecessor of x and y
is on the nearest slacky level
and we're going to figure out the
estimate of that green area
and pick the maximum one so we'll
estimate the green area
divide and divide by the
number of points between x and y and
figure out the average value
and that's how we'll do it we'll go
through every single point
x and do this so
this is not going to be sublinear time
but we will reuse the samples
so we don't need that many samples but
we do need a lot of running time to do
this
okay so that's the algorithm essentially
the rough idea for the lower bound is
we show an omega n over login lower
bound on a different
property which we're going to call t
bigness okay this is joint work with
maria maliak barpur temesculiakis john
peebles and anakiya penani
we look at this property called t
bigness and this property has nothing to
do with monotonicity
it just says a distribution has the t
bigness property if every domain element
has probability
at least t okay and think of t as being
something like
epsilon over the domain size
so everybody you know may not be quite
uniform but everybody has some
reasonable probability
so it turns out this is a symmetric
property so
the valiant valiant work should give you
a good lower bound
you can actually get a lower bound via
reduction to the
um to a framework of wu and yang
who gives somewhat better dependence on
epsilon
and a and then
once you have this n over login lower
bound on t
bigness then you can get a lower bound
on the matching postset the one that we
saw before that
seemed like a crazy postset um so we can
get a
n over login lower bound on the matching
postset
and once you get an n over login lower
bound on the matching postset
you can embed that into the hypercube
and that's where you start to lose
and you get some sort of lower bound on
the hypercube so you embed it
into a single row of the hypercube
and now what's really important is
the min to max value because everything
above the matching postset that you
embed into the hypercube
has to have at least the value of the
top
value that you put in and everything
below has can be zero
so um it's very important the specific
parameters that you can get the lower
bound on
but eventually you get some sort of
lower bound on the hypercube
okay so it leaves a lot of open
questions
for the hypercube uh
we don't have a tight bound on the
sample complexity a
we don't know if you can get some linear
runtime what happens can you extend this
to
other domains that are like hypergrids
so there's a lot of open questions just
on hypercube
we've looked at a lot of specific post
sets i mentioned
one lemma that gives you an upper bound
in terms of the the width and the
um the covering by chains of a post set
but we don't have a lot of techniques in
general
but one open problem i want to leave you
with is
whether there is a sub linear sample
monotonicity tester for distribution
on any postset maybe that's possible
so that's unclear and
in conclusion distribution testing
problems are everywhere
for many problems we need a lot fewer
samples than you might think
and there's a lot of cool ideas and
techniques that have been developed
and they've been borrowed from all sorts
of different communities
and it's really nice to see how they all
fit together
so um finally i wanted to mention that
there's
a lot more to do so i hope you all want
to work on these problems
and i want to say one more thing since
this is the um
since because of the name of this a
lecture series
i wanted to say thank you to dick carp i
was a graduate student
at berkeley when he was a faculty member
there and
he was he taught me a lot
he was super inspiring and he was
very very supportive and we all
appreciated him very much
and i think he had a big influence on my
life so i really wanted to thank him
um and then i want to thank the rest of
you for listening
fantastic thanks a lot um that was
really fascinating so
um if you want to uh ask a question
please use the q a feature
uh on on zoom and um
we'll get to those um while while
they're
thinking about that ronnie i i guess i
had a question
so so the theme throughout um has been
that you can
you know estimate a probability
distribution of some kind and then use
that for the for the testing problem
um but mostly those estimates
uh are exploiting averaging so for
monotonicity you have this special
particip
partition um for the for the directed
graphs monotonicity there or on the
hypercube you have this
you know clever approach of averaging
over the constant constant regions
um i guess it's surprising you said
early on that the plug-in
estimator's optimal for uniformity
testing
we're there you know i don't see any
averaging going on it seems like that's
a terrible estimate of the distribution
for
you know order square it in size sample
so what's the intuition for
for a plug-in estimator working in that
in that setting
that's a good question i actually i i
think it's shocking so i
i think i'm not the best person to ask
on the intuition there
maybe is there anybody on this say a
i don't know if any of the co-authors
from that paper are on this particular
call
um i don't see any of them but a that's
a really
a that was that was a shock to me and
it's
still i still haven't digested that one
but that's a good question
um in general i just want to caution you
about thinking that just because you can
learn you can test
i mean i know that that's what i'm
saying in this talk and that's sort of
my point but it's not really
i just want to caution i want a word of
caution that um
for example in the berger distribution
like even
even in the monotonicity in the
one-dimensional case
if you had had a random subset of each
of those buckets
you know you would have had to
distinguish that from um
like you could have had a distribution
that knows the beer j buckets and picks
a random subset of each bucket
okay then you're going to have you're
going to learn something
but it's not going to be close to your
original distribution so in some sense
the learning problem can be a lot easier
than testing similarity of two
distributions
okay and so what would the um
tester do is it would have to figure out
that you're actually picking a random
subset of each bucket
um and that's really what the tester
that's why a lot of this is reducing to
uniformity testing or
or some kind of identity testing but we
also inherit the lower bounds from those
problems
uh so so usually learning
can be easier somehow in the hypercube
it was the learning problem that seemed
hard because
um there seemed to be no relationship
between
what happens in one part of the
hypercube and what happens in the other
part of the hypercube and there's lots
of parts of the hypercube
um what uh but i think your your point
about uh
that even the plug-in estimate for the
um went through and i think that's a
that is really a good thing to
understand and i i can't say i have
great insights there
oh it looks like uh clement
cannot uh has some comments to
to give um uh omid or jesse could we
could we um uh
shift clemon into be a panelist so that
we can we can hear those comments i
think it's probably much easier than
trying to read through those and in the
meantime
while they're while they're doing that
um peter
winkler posted a question ronnie uh is
it nice that the uniform distribution is
in some sense the hardest distribution
to test
for l1 near equality
um i think it's as hard as any so yes
i don't know if it would yeah yeah i
don't i think that
in some sense every distribution is this
hard but but uniformity is as hard as
anybody
uh so the valid value lower bound
applies to uniform as well
uh or at least one of the reversions did
so i think
um yes uniform is hard
great and uh clemon you you had uh
oh hi yeah so i'm not a i'm not an
author on that paper but
from my understanding because i was also
very puzzled about why the uh
empirical estimator for the l1 descent
was a good tester
it it is highly biased so whether you're
actually uniform or
epsilon far from uniform that estimator
will still be almost one
but it's like one minus little of one
and somehow between the cases there is
enough of a gap in that
lower term to allow you to test so it's
highly biased but
somehow you can still find a small gap
that allows you to get that square root
n of epsilon square
sample complexity between the two cases
which i find really surprising um
and yeah and that has good implications
as ronit mentioned in the talk because
uh it's also a test that gives high
priority statements with optimal
dependence on the
privacy
yeah i agree i was quite shocked
lots of surprises all right um
if there are no other questions uh let
me let me say
a big thank you again ronnie that was a
fascinating
and fantastic talk thank you thank you
so much
it was an honor it was thanks all